what a horrible tragedy that you lost
your girlfriend she was brilliant
brilliant brilliant film director Lynn
Shelton how'd you meet her I met her
like so you came on the podcast in like
2016 and I was a fan of her work we
began writing a script together she
directed uh several episodes a couple
episodes of my show a couple episodes of
glow with no romance during all this
work in other words sort of like if we
could feel it you know like we're
definitely making excuses to spend time
together you know why didn't you act on
it well I didn't I don't trust love and
you know too much and we were both with
other people and it became undeniable
you know but I still was sort of like no
this can't be real but she directed uh
two of my specials she I think more than
anything in my life gave me a confidence
that I I that that lives with me still
you found a person that you finally feel
like is your best friend and the love of
your life and then to lose her yeah now
I thought the story originally was that
because it was at the start of covid
that she had this medical condition and
she got covered but that's not the case
it was uh undiagnosed condition right so
so she had no idea right and uh it was
leukemia acute it was a acute myeloid
leukemia which apparently is is hard to
detect but but yeah but you know she
just got sick and um you know and and it
was like it was a week you know and it
was um but she didn't know that she had
this condition the process was like you
know she had swollen glands and she felt
sick and you know and and uh
um so it was we'll go get a cover test
and it was a negative and then she got
another one it was negative then she did
a video doctor appointment and uh told
the doctor symptoms and we'd had and the
doc said well maybe it's strep throat we
had a z-pack you know antibiotics at the
house so the doc said you know do that
but her fever wasn't breaking you know
so it was like three or four days into
the you know what was your fever how
high was it 100 100 102 you know it was
fluctuating so you wouldn't think
anything was that weird right but after
the antibiotics I got scared and I said
you know look at me you know we've got
to go and she wasn't a doctor person you
know she's definitely she was a person
that had certain conditions that she
learned how to manage through you know
vitamin supplements and food but she's
very naturopathic right
um so
so when the fever didn't break I was
like I gotta take to the doctor you know
we got to go to the doctor tomorrow
um because I was terrified and that
night the night we did I made an
appointment that night in the middle of
the night she collapsed and it woke me
up and I had to call the ambulance and
uh you know and and then uh you know
that was the they took her and that was
the last I saw her wow God when they
were taking her away
uh on the on the stretcher yeah I said
well give me your phone and she's like I
don't want to give you my phone I said
well give me the code you know I I just
I don't know I don't know why I said
that and I wrote I scribbled it down
and then it became clear that you know
she went unconscious when they got her
there and she was fighting for her life
that day and and I had to tell an ICU
nurse I had to say get into her phone
and get me some sheltons because I don't
know them
like I had to figure out who her father
was who her mother never met the father
because it was a new a fairly regulation
I met I met him at a film festival you
know when we were with the movie but not
as her her boyfriend so like this is how
I'm meeting these people because she put
me down I was in the emergency contact
because she didn't think she was going
to be dying so like I I said you know I
shouldn't be the point person here here
you know like I got her father looked in
they're both married to different people
I got her mother looped in and uh you
know so that was the circle of contacts
during the day but because I was still
the name on there you know I still had
to you know they were coming to me first
and then I'd call her father and then
get her mother it was a horrible day you
know dealing with friends trying to hold
on to hope and
but I'll tell you man you know
outside of the stuff I talked about and
especially you know after she passed
away you know I I had to I reached out
to her her ex-husband yeah and I said
look man I know that there's no reason
for us to talk really but but I was with
her after this last week and if you if
you want to know what what it was like
or if you have any questions you know
we we uh we can talk
and uh yeah and and we did and it was it
was rough man and it but it wasn't rough
in like an anger way it was just two men
crying you know on a phone going through
you know this you know this week you
know I just wanted him to be up to speed
well what a beautiful thing you did by
calling him I mean not everybody would
have done that Mark not everyone would
have done that right it was some real
some real uh man you know it was
heavy
thank you